Hey it's me Destin welcome back to Smarter Every Day. So you probably didn't know that Alabama
has it's own museum of natural history. We also have
the only meteorite to ever strike a human being. Want to check it out?
It's known as the Hodges meteorite. It's 8.5 pounds and it hit
this woman.. Ann Hodges. It's pretty funny because she was taking a nap
on her couch and she was rudely awakened by a huge
fireball coming through her roof and nailing her on the leg.
It was so forceful, it broke her radio.
They didn't know if this meteorite belonged to the people that own the house,
or Miss Hodges because it hit her. But the people that own the house, they wanted it,
so they went to court. Long story short, she bought it from those
people anyway. Now it's here at the Alabama Natural History Museum.
So now you know. The only meteorite ever to strike a person happened in
1954 in Alabama. I'm Destin. You're getting Smarter Every Day.
Let's go hug a whale fossil.
Not interested. I'll do it.
(Wife) What are you doing?
(Destin) Did you know there used to be elephants in Alabama?
Come look at this. That's an
elephant tooth. It's called a mastadon.
(Son) Mastadon elephant.
(Destin) They used to live in Alabama. You believe me?
- Yes.
- Pretty awesome isn't it?
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]
captionsbyandrew.wordpress.com
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.